HILLARY BERGH: Hello.
Welcome, everyone.
I'm here with Chef Carla Hall.
It's very exciting
to be here with you.
So, those of you
that don't know,
she was a finalist on the
fifth and the eighth season
of "Top Chef" on
Bravo-- yes-- and is
a current co-host
on "the Chew" talk
show on ABC, which is
a lot of fun to watch.
So we're here, or she's here.
We're going to talk about the
new book, "Carla's Comfort
Foods."
Yes.
I'm the chef at Root Cafe.
My name's Hillary Bergh, and--
CARLA HALL: [APPLAUSE]
HILLARY BERGH: Thank you.
CARLA HALL: I ate
there yesterday.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
It was a lot of fun.
We had a little chat
over lunch, impromptu.
And then today, we did a
whole menu based on her book.
So hopefully, some of you
were able to join for that.
And, if not, now you know
that next time, when there's
a chef on campus, I write
a menu from their book.
You have another
book that you wrote.
CARLA HALL: Uh-huh.
"Cooking With Love."
And it's primarily comfort
foods from the Sunday suppers
where I grew up in Nashville,
Tennessee, and also
a lot of the recipes
that I did on Top Chef--
the chicken pot pie, the Jimmy
Fallon-- that's in there.
The Last Supper Buttered
Tarragon Peas are in this book.
But the meal that I did
at Ellis Island-- that's
in there-- that I
really thought I
should have won
because it was so good.
But I didn't.
So that's in there.
The oyster stew, where I won
the car, that's in there.
Anything that won a prize is
in there-- or I should have won
is in there.
HILLARY BERGH: Very good.
And then, you and some of the
other co-hosts on "The Chew"
wrote a cookbook together, too.
CARLA HALL: Right.
Well, we "wrote" it,
in that we're on ABC,
and we work there, and
they took our recipes
and put them in that book.
HILLARY BERGH: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
CARLA HALL: (WHISPERING)
Crap, it's video.
[LAUGHTER]
CARLA HALL: (WHISPERING) We
don't get paid for that one.
[LAUGHTER]
HILLARY BERGH: So
anyway, all right.
Well, I really liked how much
you spoke about connections
through food.
And I'm sure that you noticed,
when we ate yesterday,
there's a lot of communal
tables in the cafes,
and when you got to go around.
So, can you speak a
little about how important
that is to not only just
be eating good food,
but to make these connections?
CARLA HALL: Right,
it's about community.
Well, the inspiration
for this book
came from the political
climate, our polarizing, very
dysfunctional political climate.
In 2012, when I
was thinking, it's
so terrible that they polarize
each other's differences,
and it's like repelling magnets.
And I was thinking, how
can I show through food
how we're very
similar as people?
And our differences
should be celebrated.
So the spices, basically,
are the differences.
And it should be celebrated.
So take the first
set of recipes that I
thought about that
would actually
share my thinking was
chicken and milk gravy, which
is basically a smothered
chicken dish in the South,
like sausage and gravy, that
white gravy that you put on
that you hope is not
too thick that's yummy?
OK, so that's the
chicken and milk gravy.
But if you take the milk out and
you add sour cream and paprika,
you could be in Hungary.
If you take the milk out and you
add heavy cream, dijon mustard,
white wine, and tarragon,
you could be in France.
Or if you take the milk out
and you add tomatoes, habanero
peppers, and maybe
plantains or bananas,
you could be in West Africa.
But at the end of
the day, they're
all a smothered chicken dish.
You're just changing the spices.
And they should be celebrated.
It shouldn't be where, well,
I eat smothered chicken
where I live with milk gravy.
And just because you're having
it with wine and heavy cream,
I don't like you, and I'm
never going to taste your food.
I mean, how crazy is that?
And so this is what
this book is about.
And it's about sharing and
honoring and celebrating
people and their food.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah,
that's wonderful.
We spoke a little bit
yesterday about how
my cafe goes all around the
world in our menu, and--
CARLA HALL: I know.
Have you guys been there?
Right?
I mean, I know you
work here, right.
Of course you've been there.
I'm just so amazed how you were
in Cambodia, and then Russia,
and then you were
in the Philippines.
It was amazing.
Like, day after day.
It wasn't like you've
got all this stuff
and you get to turn
it over after a week.
That's a lot of work, y'all.
That's a lot of work.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
No, it is a lot of work.
But it's interesting
for my cooks.
They get to apply
this technique where
it's the same basic
technique with just
a few little moderations of
what the ingredients are.
So it's really
unique, and you get
to learn about that in the book.
CARLA HALL: So one of
the things that I do.
I mean, in the book, of course,
there are all of these recipes.
And in the vegetable
chapter, I will
take my favorite vegetables
because it's my book.
So peas-- I mean, you know, I
may never get to do it again.
So when you write your book,
you put your favorite vegetables
in it.
But peas, corn,
squash, cauliflower.
So I take my favorite
vegetables and I change them
with those spices.
But let's say that
you are somebody
who cooks a lot at home.
There's a spice chart.
I have the international
spice chart.
And in that spice chart,
you have the aromatics,
which would be your fresh
ingredients like onions,
garlic, peppers, all of that.
And then, you have
you're fresh herbs.
your dried spices,
the things that make
that cuisine unique,
and then whatever
miscellaneous ingredients.
So I have these 18
different cuisines.
So, let's say you
make a meatloaf
and you want to change it.
You already know how
to make meatloaf.
So, now what you
do to change it up
is to go to one of
those different cuisines
and just mix it up a little bit.
So now, instead of one recipe,
you have 18 different recipes.
HILLARY BERGH: Mhm.
Yeah, the spice chart
was really cool.
CARLA HALL: Yeah.
Did you agree with
it or disagree?
HILLARY BERGH: I agreed, yeah.
I wanted to add a few
more things on there.
CARLA HALL: I know, I know.
And let me tell you
why I didn't exactly.
Did you want to add things that
were more exotic or-- right.
HILLARY BERGH:
Some unique things.
CARLA HALL: Some unique things.
And I didn't do
that specifically
because when you think
about international food,
you think that you have to go
to a specialty food market.
And I'm honestly trying to
make this so approachable to--
and I think about
Middle America.
I just want to make
it very approachable
for them, so that they're
not going to get scared.
And not only are the
ingredients approachable,
but the recipes
are approachable.
The time.
I thought about, can you make
a lot of them during the week?
So I steered away from
those exotic things.
HILLARY BERGH: That makes sense.
Yeah.
And there's not a Middle Eastern
market on the corner of every--
CARLA HALL: --store in Iowa.
HILLARY BERGH: Right.
Yes.
So, cool.
So I know that you were inspired
by your grandma, Thelma.
You didn't get to
really cook with her,
but inspired by
her, which is great.
CARLA HALL: Thelma and Granny.
I have two grand-- Yeah.
My grandmothers cooked
so well, and it just
leaped right over my mom.
You know, whoop!
HILLARY BERGH: Well, it happens.
And I had a lot of fun
growing up and cooking
with my grandma [? Idebel. ?]
[? CARLA HALL: Idebel? ?]
[? HILLARY BERGH: Idebel. ?]
CARLA HALL: Oh my-- cute!
Freddie Mae and [? Idebel, ?]
they would've been-- oh my god.
Together, they are a pair.
HILLARY BERGH:
Best friends, yes.
So how important is it to
get our youth involved,
and to pass down
these traditions?
CARLA HALL: It's so important.
As a matter of fact, the
first cookbook that I wrote,
I was actually thinking
about my niece.
Now, my sister
doesn't like to cook.
My niece kind of likes to cook.
We weren't there
with my grandmother.
I didn't start cooking
until I was about 25
and went to culinary
school at 30.
And so then, I was trying
to backpedal and say,
oh, gosh, what are you making?
And then, my grandma Thelma
had passed away already.
And then my grandmother, Granny,
Freddie Mae, she was already
in her late 80s,
going into her 90s.
By the way, my mother was still
going to Lebanon, Tennessee,
30 miles outside of
Nashville, to get those Sunday
suppers to take to
work for her lunch.
OK, I'm just saying.
I mean, my grandmother was
still cooking for my mom at 94.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
Let's see, my
grandmother was 92,
and she was still cooking
every Sunday for all of us.
CARLA HALL: Right?
You know?
And then you don't realize
that they were sick
until the macaroni
started slipping.
And you're like,
wait, are you OK?
I mean--
HILLARY BERGH: This is a
little different, right?
CARLA HALL: Yeah.
Right.
What happened?
You notice in the food.
It's that you're
talking to them,
but you're really
focused on the food.
OK.
So anyway.
It's so important
for those traditions
to be carried down the line.
And unless the kids
are actually in there--
and I think with our
food-- and even though I'm
talking about
international food,
I really like the fact
that we can keep our food
segregated so it's not so
homogenized and blending
with other cuisines.
Because it's about history.
It's like this [? grio ?] that
you're passing on these stories
along.
And it's nice.
And if they all mix,
then, for the generations
that are younger than us, they
forget what Southern food is,
or what Indian food is, or what
all of these different cuisines
are.
HILLARY BERGH: Honoring
that authenticity.
CARLA HALL: Exactly.
Exactly.
And just loving
it for what it is.
And then you can
mix, but as long
as they know what
the original was.
But I think, because of
shows like the Food Network
and Bravo and "Chopped" and
all of these different shows,
kids are getting more
involved in food,
and the world is
getting smaller.
And they're actually
putting chefs on pedestals.
I don't know if that's so
great, but the great thing
is, they want to be cooks.
And they want to
eat different foods.
And they're playing
with their food,
unlike back in the
day when they're like,
I will only eat a grilled
cheese and plain rice
and plain chicken.
Now, I heard a kid-- I
was at a grocery store--
and the kid was
crying because they
didn't have the
sushi that he wanted.
And I wasn't even here.
I mean, I could understand if
I was here on the west coast.
I was in-- I mean, because I'm
sure all the kids are like,
ah, I don't like that
sushi, I want-- you know.
But I was in Maryland.
And I'm like, oh my
god, that's crazy.
No, it was in Pittsburgh.
HILLARY BERGH: Oh, that's cool.
CARLA HALL: Right?
Isn't that cool?
HILLARY BERGH: Surprising.
CARLA HALL: It was
very surprising.
I'm like, kid, you cry.
You cry for your sushi!
HILLARY BERGH: That's right.
CARLA HALL: You know.
Right?
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
There's a child care center.
Not here on campus, but
there's four of them
that the Googlers can
send their kids to.
And the chef there has
told me many stories where
the parents have
called her and said,
my kid is asking for this
quinoa salad that you made.
My kid is asking for
these kale chips.
Can you-- how do I make them?
What is this?
CARLA HALL: Exactly.
HILLARY BERGH: So
it's really cool.
CARLA HALL: It's really cool.
And that's what's so
important about kids
being involved in food.
Because what happens,
I think, as adults,
we tend to put them
in these boxes.
But when kids have
an experience,
and they take that
experience home,
then they're broadening
their parents'
idea of what they would want.
And so then, the parents
are getting those things.
And it's this big cycle
that should continue.
And it's so beautiful to see.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah,
it is, for sure.
So you alluded a little bit
to TV a few minutes ago.
What are some secrets you
might be able to share with us?
Because, is there
really cooking going on?
CARLA HALL: There's
really cooking.
Some things not good.
Some things are not a winner.
There are some things,
and-- so we actually
do cook in real time.
And some of the things
are so delicious.
And a lot of times, you'll
see us start a dish.
And then there's a
commercial break,
and we finish cooking that dish
during the commercial break.
And we come back and we eat it.
Especially things that
cook very quickly.
I mean, stews, you
can't do that with.
So you put them together,
and there's a slot.
But for the most part, we
really try to do those quickly.
Those dishes that cook
quickly, we are eating them.
As a matter of
fact, we've kind of
got a little snobbish about it.
So the culinary team will
bring some of those dishes
from the kitchen.
But they were
cooked, because they
have to stagger everything
and make them ahead of time.
And we're like, oh,
I don't want that.
I want the dish that
was just cooked,
that's hot and delicious,
that Mario made.
No offense to the kitchen
staff, but, you know.
HILLARY BERGH: Well,
that's good to know,
because that shows you how
quickly you can make something
at home, right?
CARLA HALL: Right.
I mean the "5 in 5"
that Michael does,
his little segment
called "5 in 5."
So it's five ingredients,
five minutes or less,
and he makes it right there.
So if it takes Michael
five minutes-- I mean,
maybe it's going to take
somebody at home 20 minutes.
But still, that's fast, to
get dinner on the table.
And sometimes, his
pan will be too hot,
and there are all kinds of
antics that are going on.
And Mario is like, yeah, chef.
You haven't had the pasta in,
and you have one minute left.
Yeah, let's see if
you're going to make it.
But it's still really
fun to show people
that they can have a really
quick meal under 30 minutes.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah, absolutely.
And I know that all of you
are working long hours.
I'm certainly
working long hours.
So little tips and
tricks, anything else
you might share with us?
So we need to watch the
show for the "5 in 5."
CARLA HALL: Yeah, you
need to watch the show.
Here's a funny story.
It has nothing to do with food.
HILLARY BERGH: We're
ready, I'm sure.
CARLA HALL: So when
the show first started,
I had to get used to-- the
transition from "Top Chef"
to where I'm just
cooking and there happens
to be a camera-- to actually
hosting a show where you're
cooking, you're
talking to a guest,
you're telling the audience
a little bit about yourself,
all of these things.
You're juggling.
It's really harder
than you think.
I mean, it's multitasking
like nobody's business.
And we have found,
and studies of shown,
that multitasking
really doesn't work.
But it's kind of boring when
you have to cook something
and you're just like,
whatever, hold on,
and you're just focusing
on that one thing.
So you have to multitask, OK.
So I have an IFB in my ear
where the executive producer
talks in your ear.
And he helps you go along.
If you need to move on,
he will say, hey, move on.
He'll say, "great"
and then you move on.
"Fantastic," you move on.
So this was in the
beginning before I'm
used to someone
talking in my ear.
Usually, if I hear
voices in my head,
they're mine, not somebody
else's with this deep voice
with an Australian accent.
So I have the IFB.
I'm actually interviewing
this person, I'm cooking,
and I'm doing this egg dish.
And he just keeps
saying "egg," "egg."
And he just keeps saying it.
That's all he's saying, "egg."
So I'm hearing "egg."
And let say I'm interviewing
you, and I'm like, "egg."
He says "egg." "Egg."
I'm literally
saying it out loud.
I just keep saying "egg."
And then, I look
over at Michael.
He's like this,
cracking up laughing.
Because I'm like, why
does he keep saying "egg"?
He doesn't say, "put the
egg," "don't forget the egg."
So he just says this
one word, "egg."
So I'm like, you need
to give me more words.
OK, so keep that in your head.
So then, let's fast forward.
Now it's season two.
And this is what
I get in my ear.
"Carla, well, you know,
what I think you should do
is talk to them about--
you know, there's an egg."
I'm like, why are you
giving me so many words?
He's having a
conversation in my ear.
I'm like-- And so sometimes,
if you watch the show,
I'm like this.
Because I'm answering
those voices in my head,
which is kind of crazy.
The food is usually really good.
You can tell.
I don't fake it.
If I don't like something,
my face really can't--
HILLARY BERGH: It's
not going to hold back.
CARLA HALL: It doesn't.
I'm like-- So most of the things
that Mario makes are delicious.
I love me some Mario Batali.
But one time, at band
camp, Mario made this dish.
It was panettone.
Delicious.
He made a French toast with
panettone with maple syrup.
Delicious.
And you know, Mario makes
really good meatballs
with the tomato sauce.
He actually has a tomato
sauce that you can buy.
Delicious.
But this particular
day, he decided
to take that meatball,
and that tomato sauce,
and that beautiful panettone
with that maple syrup,
do a mashup.
HILLARY BERGH: Uh-oh.
CARLA HALL: Oh, no.
I'm sure they don't
eat it in Italy.
And I'm very sure they should
not have it here in America.
It was not a winner.
And I was like--
Yeah, it wasn't good.
HILLARY BERGH: Did
he really like it?
He thought it was--
CARLA HALL: I was
looking at him,
and I said-- I said, do
you really like this?
Because when Mario doesn't
like something, he's like this.
Like that one time that Clinton
decided to make an eggnog.
And with raw eggs.
OK.
And Mario's like, I'm
not having that eggnog.
Right.
But everybody else had some.
And on the way home, if
you were on the train--
HILLARY BERGH: Uh-oh.
CARLA HALL: --you
were having issues.
We were all texting
each other, saying,
I had to take a meeting.
I had to run to the
bathroom and take a meeting.
That's code for having to
go to the bathroom for us.
And it wasn't good.
Mario said, I told
you guys not to have
that eggnog with those fresh
eggs that weren't so fresh.
HILLARY BERGH: Maybe if they
had been from someone's chicken
in the backyard--
CARLA HALL: Exactly.
Like "Portlandia,"
you knew that chicken.
You're like, is that from Sam?
Sam, did you cluck
that chicken out?
Yes, exactly.
But no, we didn't
know those chickens.
HILLARY BERGH:
Nope, that's risky.
Raw chicken.
CARLA HALL: Risky, risky.
A word to the wise.
HILLARY BERGH: So, comfort
food, there's always
this stigma of it's
heavy, it's greasy.
But you take a very healthy
approach here, which I like.
I have a very healthy
approach in my cafe.
And people that haven't
eaten my food yet-- or maybe
you can relate to
before you were famous--
and they look at me and they
go, but you're so skinny.
Your food must not be good.
CARLA HALL: Girl, I know.
Never trust a skinny chef.
You get that all
the time, right?
HILLARY BERGH: Yes.
CARLA HALL: Do
you eat your food?
HILLARY BERGH: Right?
CARLA HALL: I know, I know.
I get it, too.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah?
CARLA HALL: I get it, too.
HILLARY BERGH: So
what do you do?
CARLA HALL: The funny
thing is people,
oftentimes, they say, oh, you
have this healthy approach
to your food.
And I don't think
of it that way.
I think that it's
just how I cook.
I want to taste the food.
I want to taste the ingredients.
I want to taste the
vegetables that I'm using.
So I don't want to put
a lot of fat into it.
I don't want to
put a lot of bacon.
If I'm having bacon,
I'm having bacon.
But if I'm having grains,
I'm having grains.
If I'm having hot
water cornbread, which
you guys probably
know nothing about,
you can have a
little bit of fat.
Has anybody had hot
water cornbread?
What?
Where are your
people from, girl?
AUDIENCE: Louisiana.
CARLA HALL: Ah!
OK, so hot water cornbread.
Let's just take a little
time out, a little break.
Hot water cornbread
is white cornmeal.
And you have a
little bit of fat,
and some salt, and no sugar.
By the way, Southerners,
for the most part,
if they're real
Southerners, they
like everything sweet
but their cornbread.
It's OK to drop a whole five
pounds of sugar in your tea.
That's fine.
But you do not put
it in the cornbread.
And then, a little
bit of bacon fat.
You know, bacon grease.
And you make this
mush with hot water.
You make a mush, and then you
make them into little patties
and you fry it.
So inside, it's very tender, and
the outside is kind of crispy
because it fries
in the shallow oil.
And that's what you
use with-- you have it
with beans and collard
greens and stews,
because it's for sopping.
Which is why we don't
have sweet cornbread,
because it's for sopping.
Why did I start
talking about this?
HILLARY BERGH: We were
talking about healthy food
and the healthy approach.
But fat is still good.
There's fat in here.
Fat is good, but--
CARLA HALL: Fat is good, but
I want to taste the food.
I want to taste it.
And so my grandmother, who was
born in 1908, at a time when
people were having
a lot of hog jaws
and all of that in her food,
her husband-- my grandfather,
[? Doc-- ?] had
high blood pressure.
And so she took that
out of her food.
So I grew up having a lighter
version of Southern food.
And I think that
comfort food for me
is all the food that you
might have in your kitchen,
where somebody who loves
you is making for you.
And so, when you're
feeling low, you
go back to those food
memories for that thing.
And so it changes for everybody.
I mean, in San Francisco,
it may be your cioppino.
And that doesn't have
a lot of fat in it.
It's a seafood stew, right?
But it's different
for everybody.
And I wanted to celebrate what
could be comfort food for one
and a delicacy for
another, or whatever.
And that's with
this book is about.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah,
that's very cool.
So, as a female in
our industry, we're
usually in the minority
in the kitchens.
I know that in many of the
departments here at Google,
women are also the minority.
CARLA HALL: Move over, men.
They're coming.
It is the year of the woman.
I think the decade of the woman.
OK, go ahead.
Sorry.
HILLARY BERGH: Well, can
you speak a little bit?
So, as a woman, how can
you empower yourself?
How can you rise to the top and
not be intimidated or not be
called the B-word because
you're standing strong, or--
CARLA HALL: Right.
Right.
I think for me,
first off, I always
wanted to do something
that I loved.
I mean, it was my job.
My parents told me, it's
your job to be happy.
So wherever I am, I want to be.
And there's confidence
that knowing that--
and also, I'm a Taurus.
So I think my
stubbornness protects me.
Because if I want to
be there, I'm all in.
You can't tell me to leave.
I'm all in.
But I think what's also
helped me is that I'm tall.
HILLARY BERGH: Yes, I agree.
CARLA HALL: Right?
Especially in a kitchen.
When you're around
a lot of men--
no offense-- when you're
around a lot of guys,
it helps that you are
tall because you're
looking at someone in the
eye versus looking at them
down here.
And I know that, in the
kitchen, some of my friends
who aren't as tall, they had a
totally different experience.
And also, I was older when
I came into the kitchen.
So I went to culinary
school at 30.
So I came in at a time where
I knew I wanted to be here.
I have left a career
that I didn't like.
So I'm here, and
I'm here to stay.
And I knew that I
could work long hours.
I know that I'm strong.
Physically strong, as well
as just emotionally strong.
So I think determination
has a lot to do with it.
And just basically digging
your heels in and saying,
I'm here to stay.
And I think, as women,
we apologize a lot
because we're very nurturing.
So we want everyone else
to feel really good.
And we have to stop that.
And it doesn't make us a bitch.
So what?
If you're-- oh.
HILLARY BERGH: Oh, yeah.
That's fine.
We've said it now.
Do you want me to say it
too, so you feel better?
So there's no bitching.
No bitches, right?
CARLA HALL: Right.
HILLARY BERGH: But
we're-- you know.
No, we're not bitches.
CARLA HALL: It's
like that-- What
is the Keele and-- what is it?
Peele and-- Matthew?
Peele and--
AUDIENCE: Key and Peele.
CARLA HALL: Yeah.
You know the Key and Peele,
with the bitch, with the wife.
And they go on all
about the wives like--
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
CARLA HALL: But anyway.
But no, we're not.
We're just strong
women and determined,
and knowing what we like.
And yeah.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah, awesome.
So I don't know.
Does anyone in here
have a Google Glass on?
No?
Oh, yes.
Cliff does.
So have you heard
about the Google Glass?
CARLA HALL: I've seen--
tell me about it.
I've seen so many people
walking around with it.
I've seen yellow
ones and pink ones.
Cliff has a grey one.
I like the green one.
HILLARY BERGH: I don't
know very many specifics,
but I do know that you can
take pictures of things,
and you can record things.
And so I'm wondering,
what kind of technology,
is there something like
that that you think
is going to be beneficial
in the cooking world,
or that could apply?
Would you want to
wear one of those
while you're cooking stuff
and do a YouTube video, or--
CARLA HALL: Well,
if I had one and I'm
doing a cooking
demonstration, and I
have to have a
recipe on the fly,
or if I have to
look something up.
Like if somebody-- is
it like "Intelligence"?
Like that show?
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah, I think
that you can Google stuff
from it, and you can make
phone calls and texts and--
AUDIENCE: There's an
app called KitchMe.
HILLARY BERGH: An
app called what?
AUDIENCE: An app called KitchMe.
HILLARY BERGH: KitchMe.
And that's for the kitchen?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
CARLA HALL: Oh, see.
I would be the smartest
girl in the room.
I mean, I can see
that, if you're
doing a demo or some kind
of talk where, let's say,
you need to see your recipe.
And you're here and on the
fly, and somebody says, well,
what else can you do
with that ingredient?
And you Google it, and
this ingredient pops up.
Well, you could do this, or
maybe you can use these spices.
Do you guys know the
book "The Flavor Bible"?
HILLARY BERGH: I love that book.
CARLA HALL: Right?
HILLARY BERGH: I love it.
CARLA HALL: I mean,
as a professional--
HILLARY BERGH: I love it.
If you don't have it,
you need to get it.
CARLA HALL: So those
of you who know it,
let me describe it to those
of you who don't know it.
So it's a book with all
of these ingredients.
And so, from A to Z, you have
all of these ingredients.
And let's say you go--
are you looking it up now?
See, if you've
got your glasses--
HILLARY BERGH: Taking a note.
CARLA HALL: Oh, OK.
So if you look up apples,
and you see everything
that goes with apples.
And then you see
on that list honey.
So then you go to H
and you find honey.
And you see everything
that goes with honey.
But on both lists,
you will see rosemary.
So then, you can cross
source the rosemary,
so you know that
honey, rosemary,
and apples go together.
And you can create this
dish with those ingredients.
And it's a really great
tool to create new dishes.
And so professionals use it.
And it's still really top,
top, top on one of the number
one books to get,
in terms of spices.
But, so something like that.
If you have all of that
information in this app,
then you could
create on the fly,
and you would be so amazing.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah,
that would be fun.
Yeah, from "The Flavor Bible,"
I was doing a wild boar dish.
And we were celebrating
Chocolate Day.
Like chocolate and boar,
chocolate and boar.
Well I ended up doing a-- so the
boar was marinated with juniper
berries overnight,
so super tender.
And then the sauce was
parsnips and heavy cream
and lavender and
white chocolate.
And it was just-- I run it at
Root like once a quarter or so.
So watch out for it.
It was so much fun doing the
investigation and then like,
this is kind of a
weird combination.
Is it going to work?
And--
CARLA HALL: It works.
It works because all of
those things in those lists,
as you cross, in
the science of it,
there is some property
in each of those foods
that make it go together, and
you don't know what it is.
I mean, there's
certain things that you
know would go together.
For instance, ratatouille.
All of those ingredients grow
together, they go together.
And those, you know.
But there are some of
these weird combinations
like white chocolate and
boar and juniper berries.
You're like, what?
What?
But then, speaking
of that, let's
say I was having a
talk with somebody,
and I wanted to
share with them ways
to get to know your palate.
And I think that's so powerful.
So obviously, when you buy my
book, it's based on my palate,
because all of the recipes,
I've tasted and said,
yes, I like them.
But let's say, if
you don't like lemon,
and I love lemon, then
nine times out of 10,
you may not like my recipes.
Or maybe they're too lemon-y.
Or maybe you try recipes
that are too spicy.
But just to get to
know your palate.
So if you have a talk, and
you say to somebody, well,
what do you like?
Well, I like sweet.
And then, you
think, OK, what are
the sweet things
that you may like?
And so you have this list,
sweet potatoes, bananas,
all of these different things.
Or let's say you like bitter.
And you have all of these
things that they like,
and certain things
that they don't like.
Let's say they don't like turnip
greens because they're bitter.
So I can tell you how you can
change that into something
that you may like by adding a
sweet or a component or salt so
that you will like it.
So it helps that person
because, I think, sometimes,
when people try a dish, and
it's made in a certain way
that they don't
like, they will say,
oh, I don't like turnip greens.
But they don't know why
they don't like them.
Or they'll say they're not good.
It's not that they're not
good, you don't like them.
And there's a difference.
And so often, people
say something isn't good
when they don't like it.
But if they understand
their palates,
then they can see how
to change certain foods
that they wouldn't
normally like.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
That's cool.
I like that.
Let's see.
So I know that you're
doing the Down at Monterey,
the Cooking for Solutions in
May, which is really cool.
That's always a fun event.
I did it a couple years ago.
So Google does-- all of
our seafood is sustainable.
We follow the Monterey
Bay watch guidelines.
Can you tell us a little bit
about sustainable seafood
and your take on that?
CARLA HALL: So this event,
Cooking for Solutions,
is so amazing.
I think I've done it, this
is probably my third time.
And I skipped a couple years.
But when you're in the
Monterey Bay, when you're here,
you're reminded why
you're doing all of this.
And I think
California has sort of
been the lead in telling
the rest of the country how
to conserve and how
to appreciate our land
and not take it for granted.
And so, when you go
to your Whole Foods,
and you see the fish that's
on the avoid list, the red.
And then you have the
yellow, and then the green.
It's so important.
And it's actually
doing this event
that I started thinking
about what fishes to buy.
Because you kind of forget.
Because they're there doesn't
mean that you have to buy them.
And sea bass, I
had to just tell--
I mean, in this industry,
I think, when we cook
and we see the food
rules, so to speak,
but we forget that the
lay person doesn't know.
So my sister, who
loves Chilean sea bass,
I have to go and tell
her, well, Kim, you really
shouldn't have that.
Honestly, if you go to a
restaurant and they have it,
then they probably are
having a lot of other fish
that they should not
have on their menu.
And I would like for you
not to go there, please.
And it's our responsibility
in being chefs and working
with food to lead the
charge and tell people what
they should and should not have.
And it starts with us.
So I take that responsibility
very seriously,
as I take the responsibility
of cooking for someone very
seriously.
Because, if I'm in a bad
mood-- and I say this--
if you're in a bad mood, the
only thing you should make
is a reservation.
And at that point, you pray
that whoever made your food
there is in a good
mood, because you'll
think it's the blue fish that's
off, and it was the chef.
HILLARY BERGH: That's true.
The energy that's in
the kitchen definitely
translates into the food.
Absolutely.
Cook with love.
Always cook with love.
Yes.
So you were on NPR recently.
And one of the things that
really caught my attention
was your take on salt.
And I loved the
compliments versus insults
that you referred to.
Can you share with them that?
CARLA HALL: Yes, let
me pick somebody out
to share this with.
Sir?
OK.
So what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Aaron.
CARLA HALL: Aaron?
All right.
So Aaron, are you old
enough to have gone back
for your class reunion?
OK, great.
I don't know.
I went to my class
reunion, and I
realized that Santa
Claus was in my class.
I'm like, whoa.
So Aaron, you go back to your
high school class reunion,
and they say, oh,
Aaron, you look so good.
Oh, let me just back up.
I call salt compliments,
like Hillary said.
But too many compliments
is an insult.
So that's the idea.
But to get people to get
their head around it, you say,
Aaron you look really good.
And you're like, thanks.
You're like, yeah.
And you're smiling
at this point.
And they're like, no,
you look really good.
Have you guys seen Aaron?
Doesn't he look good?
Oh, my god, you look so good.
Oh, you look good.
So then, at this point,
you're thinking, well damn.
What did I look like before?
I mean, right?
Because again, too many
compliments is an insult.
And the same thing with salt.
Salt is perfect if it
is used in moderation
and it goes into the food.
And as you're cooking, you
add salt into the food.
Like the church in the
steeple, that whole thing.
So the salt has to go into
the fiber of the food.
But if you use too much,
you can't take it out,
and it ruins the dish.
And sometimes, people
may not use salt,
and they will put
it on the table.
And they're very proud of that.
They're like, oh, I don't
use salt in my food.
It's on the table.
And I'm like, thank you
for letting me know,
I don't have to go to the table.
Because when you add salt,
and you're putting salt
on top of the food,
it's only on top.
So it's not going into the food.
So you keep adding salt and
adding salt and adding salt.
And then you over-salt.
And then all of a
sudden, you have
this dish that you can't eat.
Or when you buy processed
foods, what you have said
is, thank you for
salting my food for me.
You've given your power
away, because they've
salted it for you.
And so this is what I
always try to tell people.
When you're cooking
from scratch,
and it looks like chefs
use a lot of salt.
But you're cooking from
scratch, and I know,
and you're like, let it rain.
And in Mario, it's like roar.
And the food is dusty.
It's like a covering of
white dust on your food.
But if it's a big piece
of meat, it can take that.
It can take that salt.
But again, too much salt--
too many spices-- too much
of anything is an insult
because you're not
tasting the food
itself, now you're only
tasting the things
that you put on it.
HILLARY BERGH: Right.
Just enough to enhance
what's already going on.
CARLA HALL: Right, exactly.
Nature.
And this is another thing.
And this is why in a cookbook--
speaking of nature-- nature
gives you this ingredient
the decimals or whatever
and it changes so the
terrorists may be sweet today
and tomorrow they're not sweet.
So that's why it's so
important to taste your food
because you can't
read in the cookbook,
oh, a 1/2 teaspoon of
salt and then, well,
hey, her food
doesn't taste great.
Because you're using ingredients
and you have to kind of taste
to determine what
that needs that day.
HILLARY BERGH: Yes.
To taste.
CARLA HALL: Yeah.
HILLARY BERGH: Right.
Well, are there any
questions from any of you
that you'd like to ask Carla?
CARLA HALL: OK
you, you, then you.
HILLARY BERGH: All right.
You want to--
CARLA HALL: OK, yes,
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Natasha.
CARLA HALL: Hi, Natasha.
You look good, girl.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I was wondering, because
I saw you on "Top Chef,"
and I loved seeing
"The Chew" when
I am at home, which is
usually on a sick day.
But I'm wondering what
would be your perfect job
or perfect show that
you want to be on?
What would that be like?
CARLA HALL: Well right
now, it is my job
to talk and eat with my friends.
And I get paid.
I mean, it doesn't get
any better than that.
I mean, it's pretty perfect.
I work three days a week,
I get there at 6:30.
I leave around 2:00.
And then people invite
me to eat more later.
HILLARY BERGH: That
does sound pretty great.
CARLA HALL: It sounds
pretty awesome.
I have a four-day weekend.
I mean, I know it
sounds really awesome.
I mean that.
But I have to work and putting
together recipes and stuff,
but it's pretty great.
It's pretty great.
Cooking without a clock
like on "Top Chef"?
Go be fabulous?
Yeah, this is pretty awesome.
HILLARY BERGH: Nice.
I think we had-- let's see, you
have a microphone back there?
All right.
AUDIENCE: Carla, I'm Chelsea.
CARLA HALL: Hi, Chelsea.
AUDIENCE: I like your
show and your everything.
CARLA HALL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I actually didn't
know the part of your story
that you didn't go to culinary
school until your 30s.
CARLA HALL: Right.
AUDIENCE: So for anyone
who's [INAUDIBLE] who
may want that to happen in
the future, that's inspiring.
But where would you go if
you were to, like, be 26?
CARLA HALL: And my
name is Chelsea?
AUDIENCE: If your
name was Chelsea.
[INAUDIBLE] into the industry?
What would you do, even
if it's [INAUDIBLE]?
CARLA HALL: What I do, even if
my name wasn't Chelsea-- hint,
hint-- does your boss know that
you are thinking of leaving?
AUDIENCE: No no, I'm
not thinking of leaving,
but I just want to
be more [INAUDIBLE].
CARLA HALL: Oh OK.
So you want to do
it on the side?
I would say recreational
cooking classes are perfect.
A lot of culinary
schools, not only
do they do certificate
programs, but they also
do classes on the side.
Volunteering for places
like Sur La Table,
I think they have
a cooking program
and they take volunteers
so you don't have to pay.
I would do that.
You can do that as an option.
If you really want
to get into it
and you don't want to do the
whole certificate program,
sometimes there are
evening programs,
where there are about
six to eight weeks
where you get the basics.
And let me just be clear, going
to culinary school is great.
It gives you the technique.
But it's that technique
and your experiences
that give you the thing
that you probably wanting.
So for me, I was 30 and
I went to culinary school
because I had to
do a jump start.
Did you go to culinary school?
HILLARY BERGH: I did, I
had been in the kitchens.
My parents owned restaurants.
Since I was six or seven,
I was in the kitchens.
And I went to
culinary school at 18.
I learned some stuff, but,
I already kind of knew it.
CARLA HALL: Right.
So you already knew that stuff.
You probably didn't need to go.
HILLARY BERGH: I just
wanted the certificate.
CARLA HALL: Right.
So you just wanted
that piece of paper
to say that, I did something.
And also, you were
18, so you probably
wanted to have an experience
of going to school.
HILLARY BERGH: Yes.
CARLA HALL: As a
career changer, I
went because I
needed a jump start.
But for you, I would maybe
take that abbreviated course
where you get technique,
and then you just play.
And then you take
one-off classes
and play and cook
for your friends.
When I went to culinary
school, I actually
would get my friends
to buy the ingredients
and I would go and cook.
Whatever turned out, turned out.
If it was bad, I'm like, hey,
I don't know what I'm doing.
There's always a way out.
You always look
for that door out.
Did I see another
person over here?
AUDIENCE: I've watched
you on "Top Chef,"
and I just love the show.
And I wanted to
ask, what are some
of things about the show that
aren't obvious to the viewers?
What does it take to be really
successful on that show other
than cooking skills?
CARLA HALL: Yes, well,
there are about 90 people
working on the show.
We have really
amazing producers.
And the producers, we have
the executive producers,
but we also have the people
who put the topics together.
The producers actually come to
us with a theme of the show.
And we work from that theme,
and then they have this grid.
So that helps us narrow,
zoom in on the dishes
that we might put
together for that show.
So they'll come in and say,
Carla, we're doing a show.
"Batter up" is the theme.
And so we are doing
something with batter.
And Michael is already doing
something with the meat.
Mario's doing this.
Can you do a dessert?
So there's that part of it.
Like I said, it's so hard to
cook and talk to somebody.
And you want to make
a good dish and relate
to the people who
are watching you.
That was the biggest
transition for me.
And so it just
comes with practice.
But it also helps to--
like in the beginning,
I would read through the
entire script of the show,
and then whoever we had coming
on the show, I felt like Oprah.
In my head I said, this is
Oprah reading a book the night
before she sees a guest.
So then you know that you're
going to have a guest.
So you want to know a
little bit about them.
And so you watch
all these clips.
You go down this rabbit
hole of who they are.
And you want to have
some information just
to connect with them.
So there's all of that.
And that's what I'm doing after
2 o'clock, when I say I'm off
but I'm not really off.
So just absorbing
all that information
and being 50 and having
that hormone that
takes your mind
away is hard, too.
I don't remember a darn thing.
I mean I'm like, I have three
things to tell you, one, blah,
blah, blah, two, blah,
blah, blah, three-- three?
I guess it wasn't important.
So all of that.
So it's a balance of all that.
But the best thing that
you may or may not see,
is that we have the
support of each other.
So let's say I do forget
something but Michael's right
there.
He's like, oh, Carla, what
about blah, blah, blah?
And then so we have that between
each other, which is amazing.
If it wasn't for
Michael and Mario
specifically about how
to balance that food
and doing the demo
and interview,
I would have been totally lost.
I really relied on them.
Clinton had also done
a lot of television.
And the thing that
he told me was
to be authentic, to be yourself.
And what a lot of people may not
know, after the first season,
I went to a media trainer.
And it really wasn't
to learn how to do TV,
it was trying to be the best me
I could be in front of a camera
and not have those inhibitions.
HILLARY BERGH: Ah, cool.
Let's see.
I think we had
another question here.
We got the microphone up to you.
AUDIENCE: So with
a lot of new cooks,
they seem to be really
intimidated by the oven,
but right away
eager to cook eggs.
Eggs are so
technically difficult--
CARLA HALL: Dude!
AUDIENCE: Why do you think
this is so backwards?
I mean, sticking a
boneless, skinless chicken
breast in the oven
and clicking Broil,
you have long stretches of time.
You can be off by five
minutes, it's not a big deal.
CARLA HALL: Yeah, it is.
AUDIENCE: Eggs, it's like
five seconds, it's over.
Why do you think things
are backwards like that
for new shows?
CARLA HALL: When I was
working in the kitchen
and I was running a kitchen,
and I was having to hire people,
I would have them make
an omelette, eggs.
And I had them make
an omelette because I
could tell how they held
a pan, how cleanly they
worked, how they
use their tools.
It's a lot of finesse in
something very simple.
And I'm like, can do
the simple very well?
When I go to an ice cream
store, I want their vanilla.
When I go to a restaurant, I
want their roasted chicken.
Can you do the
simple really well?
Because a lot of
smoke and mirrors,
you can slide under the
wire with all of this.
The presentation and
sauces and your food
on one side of the
plate, thinking
that they left the
rest of it off.
You can do a lot, but can
you do the simple well?
And with eggs, are they
seasoned perfectly?
Are they fluffy?
Is the omelette
coming out of the pan?
Is it all tucked nicely?
So in culinary
school, you actually
spend about a month
on eggs, eggs alone.
I think with cooking
something like chicken,
people are afraid of it, I think
because it goes into this box.
It goes in there,
and I guess they
don't know what's
going to come out.
It's like this magic box.
But I disagree that
you have five or 10
minutes with that
chicken because people
will cook that chicken to death.
People are afraid
of raw chicken.
I mean, they are
so afraid and they
will cook it until it's dust.
HILLARY BERGH: The
health department
says 165, but at home pull
it out a little earlier.
It's going to continue to carry
over cooking on your counter.
CARLA HALL: We have
two words for you.
Residual heat.
HILLARY BERGH: Yes.
CARLA HALL: Yes.
HILLARY BERGH: All right.
Let's get the-- oh, there we go.
There's another [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question for you.
There was an article
in "The New Yorker"
this week about this crazy
dinner they had a WD~50.
They had three chefs fly
in from all over the world
to basically create all
their interpretations
of their favorite dishes ever.
What's the best meal
that you've ever had?
Because you work with
so many phenomenal chefs
over the years.
What is the most memorable
meal that you've ever done?
CARLA HALL: Oh wow, what is the
most memorable meal I've had?
HILLARY BERGH: That's hard.
CARLA HALL: I know,
it's really hard.
It's very hard.
And it also depends
on where I am
and what mood I'm
in, who I'm with.
HILLARY BERGH:
What the season is.
CARLA HALL: Yeah, the season.
I do remember when
I got to New York,
and it was probably
the first time
that I went to ABC Kitchen.
What's his restaurant?
Oh, my god.
Not Daniel Boulud.
Have you got your glasses on?
You can look that up.
AUDIENCE: George.
CARLA HALL: John George.
Thank you.
What a girl.
She didn't even
have the glasses on.
The meal was amazing.
The bread was so good.
And it was pea season.
And I love peas.
And they had the
fava bean spread.
And it was the fava
beans and the bread
was just the perfect
amount of salt.
And the spread.
And the texture.
And it was just so good.
And I was like, oh, my god.
This is the best I've ever had.
And I've said that many times.
But then I got to
dessert, and they
had this like a
strawberry shortcake.
And they had these
little tiny berries
that was so perfectly sweet.
And they had done an almost
like a-- not a coulis,
but a broth, or a syrup
of the strawberries.
And they strained it.
And it was so clear.
And it had lime in it.
And it was so perfectly
sweet and tangy.
And then these little
berries, and the whipped cream
was perfectly whipped.
And this like angel
food cake, and--
It was so good.
It was so, so good.
And I love when somebody can
take ingredients and just
let them sing.
And it's not a lot of
fuss and a 1,000 people
haven't touched it.
And that was really great.
Conversely, thinking
about that same dish,
I went to a restaurant
and it was Jersey cream
with Jersey blueberries-- it
was blueberry season-- and maple
syrup.
Doesn't that sound heavenly?
Well, I got it, and the
cream was over-whipped
just before it became butter.
And then I move the spoon back--
so that of the first thing--
then I was like, oh--
And I'm like, well, my maple
syrup wasn't even there.
It was three ingredients
on the whole dish.
One ingredient was over-whipped.
And then the other one, the
maple syrup, wasn't there.
So then I said, well, my
maple syrup isn't there.
And I didn't even
mention the cream.
So they go back and
they put the maple syrup
over the over-whipped cream,
which really curdled it up.
It was like-- And
I was like, ugh.
HILLARY BERGH: That's too bad.
CARLA HALL: It's too bad, right?
It's too bad.
So for me, the best
meal is like when
you can celebrate a chef
by making something for you
and honoring the food.
So it changes every time.
When I went to your
place, it was so good
how you transported
me to the Philippines.
It was amazing.
Not that I'm interviewing
you, but have you
been to a kamayan meal?
So tell me, Hillary, I'm
glad you could come today.
Thank you all.
HILLARY BERGH: Thank
you for having me.
CARLA HALL: Yes, of course.
Now you do such beautiful work.
And you travel the globe.
No.
Have you ever have
to kamayan meal,
like a Filipino feast, where
they do the kamayan meal where
you eat with your hands?
HILLARY BERGH: Yes, yes.
I'm forgetting the
name of the restaurant,
it's in Redwood City.
It's a sister
restaurant to Left Bank.
I think it's the Brasserie.
Anyway, the chef
there is Filipino.
And last year, he did
this whole spread.
And it was amazing.
He has a calamondin
tree in his backyard.
So he had fresh calamondins.
And then he had
also preserved some.
CARLA HALL: I just
discovered the calamondins,
that little tart, sweet
orange that-- You guys,
you have it good out here.
You have it really good.
Somebody sent me some from
Florida, it was so delicious.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
The spread--
CARLA HALL: Isn't it amazing?
HILLARY BERGH: It was amazing.
CARLA HALL: It's so good.
HILLARY BERGH: And
then, yeah, to get
to play with the
food with your hands.
CARLA HALL: Yes.
Yes.
HILLARY BERGH: I do love
eating with my hands.
CARLA HALL: I do, too.
But you know
there's an etiquette
to eating with your hands.
If you go above the
second knuckles,
you're eating like an ape.
HILLARY BERGH: There's
some delicacy to it.
CARLA HALL: Yeah,
it's so fantastic.
Yes?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I want to ask
you a question about one
of the spices you have
in your very nice chart.
It's saffron.
CARLA HALL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So first,
is there a difference
between the saffron that
is used for Persian food
and the Spanish food?
That would be the
first question.
And the second one
is, how to use it.
I been learning how
to make Spanish paella
the last couple of weeks.
And I've tried a
couple of times.
But it's a mystery
how to use it.
Lots of different
advice out there.
And it makes it so unreliable,
unpredictable the result,
right?
So maybe I should go for a
saffron in powder version?
Or I don't know-- no right?
HILLARY BERGH:
Don't do the powder.
AUDIENCE: I want to
find out a technique.
CARLA HALL: You can
use a saffron powder
if you wanted to.
AUDIENCE: I prefer
to use a thread,
but if I have a technique
that it goes well
all the time-- If you both
can give some perspective.
CARLA HALL: Is
there a difference?
Basically what the threads, and
where you are in the world--
HILLARY BERGH: I don't
know that there's actually
a difference between.
I'm sure that there
is because obviously
one plant in one
area of the world
is going to be a little bit
different in another area
of the world, even if
they're the exact same plant.
CARLA HALL: Right
because of the soil.
HILLARY BERGH: The
soil and things
will have an influence
so, I'm sure there
would be some variation.
I would think that it would
be close enough that they
should be interchangeable.
CARLA HALL: It shouldn't
change the taste.
Now how I was taught
to incorporate saffron,
I take a little bit of
water and a sugar cube.
And I actually chop
it up with the water
because the saffron won't
go flying everywhere.
So I chop it up, and
I bloom the saffron
in that little bit of water.
And then I incorporate
it like that.
How are you-- you
bloom it in water?
HILLARY BERGH: I do
bloom it in water.
Often I use dates
instead of sugar.
CARLA HALL: Oh yes.
So you grind it?
You make a little powder?
HILLARY BERGH: Mhm.
CARLA HALL: So that's
the whole thing.
I said chop it, but I
use a mortar and pestle
with a little sugar
cube and the water.
And you grind it up so you
have this saffron water that
gets incorporated into the dish.
And you use dates.
HILLARY BERGH: I use dates.
Just because I tried
not to use to much sugar
and I try to go a
more natural approach.
CARLA HALL: Well, in my
head I saw brown sugar cube.
HILLARY BERGH: Well,
hey, there you go.
CARLA HALL: I did.
HILLARY BERGH: I accept that.
CARLA HALL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So that
would be warm water.
CARLA HALL: Yes.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
HILLARY BERGH: Room temperature.
CARLA HALL: Room temperature.
Not hot.
HILLARY BERGH: Not hot.
Yeah, and the water should
turn this nice, bright yellow.
And then you know it's ready.
CARLA HALL: But too
much saffron is bitter
and it will ruin a dish.
Ruin.
HILLARY BERGH: Yeah.
A little goes a long way.
That's why it's so expensive.
You just need a
little, a few threads.
CARLA HALL: But I
want you to Tweet me
when you make that paella.
Carla Hall.
You guys can tweet me.
I actually respond
when people are nice
and they're talking about food.
I won't block you.
HILLARY BERGH: I think we have
time for one more question.
Be quick.
AUDIENCE: One thing
that stood out
to me when you
are on "Top Chef,"
apart from your
personality, was that you
had quite a few
vegetarian dishes.
And I see in the
cookbook, you also
have a non-meat section,
which as a vegetarian,
I appreciate quite a bit.
But it's unusual.
A lot of chefs focus
on meat because I
guess there's more
tah-dah effect
if you have meat in dishes.
I wonder is it just kind
of a natural inclination?
Do you make a conscious
choice to incorporate
vegetarian dishes?
CARLA HALL: A lot
of people think
that I'm actually a
vegetarian, and I'm not.
HILLARY BERGH: I get that, too.
CARLA HALL: Yeah,
you get that, too?
Two reasons-- one, I love
vegetables, it's my favorite.
I love vegetables.
The other reason, on "Top Chef,"
was because as a caterer--
and I was a caterer when
I went on "Top Chef."
Now I'm a recovering caterer.
It's been 925 days
since my last job.
This is when you guys say,
hi, Carla, keep coming back.
I would look at the menu.
So a lot of times,
we would be doing
an event where all
the food that we made
was the only food that the
people who came to the event
could have.
So I would look at everything
that people were preparing
and there wouldn't be
anything for the vegetarian.
And I'm like, well what is
the vegetarian going to eat?
This is what I'm thinking.
What are they going to eat?
Because I don't drink, I'm
always wanting the person
with the specialty
food request to feel
like, I thought about you.
And that's why I did a
lot of vegetarian foods.
And now I think it's much
easier to get vegetarian.
But whenever I was
catering, I said
please, if there
are any vegetarians,
let me know ahead of time
because I didn't want
the vegetarian to
have the sides.
And just because you are
vegetarian and it's a vegetable
does not mean that you did
not cook that vegetable
with some chicken stock.
I mean that.
My sense of catering to people
and wanting them to feel like I
thought about you.
I knew you were coming.
So here have this dish.
And also my love for vegetables.
HILLARY BERGH: OK.
Well thank you all for joining.
And it was so great meeting you.
CARLA HALL: Thank you.
HILLARY BERGH:
Two days in a row.
CARLA HALL: I know.
I can't wait to
have the goodies.
You're fantastic.
You guys have a
good one right here.
She's a good one.
HILLARY BERGH: Thank you.
CARLA HALL: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CARLA HALL: Thank you very much.
Thank you.